vous apprendrez à renvoyer barret vous
vous arrêtez vous dis très d'accord
comment vous dit merci
j'arrive à les inculper renommage
supporter le froid
pourquoi pas la nuit pourquoi pas un
ours polaire qui débarqueraient même
pourquoi pas deux mais maxime c'est au
bout de mes forces
dès qu'il ouvre ça m'énerve j'en peux
plus faux ça sans vous casser les
couilles tu te calmes car notre maxime
qui m'a sauvé arrêtez venait la vie
sauve qui en trois ans tout arrêter pour
qu'ils votent à gauche devant l'antenne
qu'est ce que tu as lui reprocher un
sommet devant isabelle non de la réalité
d'ambès je ne veux pas vous entendre on
voit marais alors qu'est ce que tu as
lui reprocher se place toujours devant
tout le monde devant isabelle as tu me
reproches et talent lorsque paul talent
je remporte la grosse tête et en gros
melon d'accord je t'aime une raclette de
la gueule et ça lui dire si je disais à
lui dire il pense que celui qui pense
qu'à l'antenne il veut juste montrer sa
tronche je veux juste montrer je prends
en préambule au général ina l'ailé dit
non a pris le melon maxi nets soit qu'il
dirige vraiment le mauvais temps
tout le monde est d'accord avec lui
faire du tout la team tentative d'accord
davy crockett pattes arrière
basic roquettes tu passes derrière tu
vas aller vanille alors bien sûr m6
porter mon cabinet hall et chérie on va
partir là pour une aventure qui va être
dangereuse si on est pas tous soudés je
vous dis tout de suite on arrête tout ok
donc vous fait un câlin ça va partir du
bon pied à l'état de vaud a qu'à la fête
voir qu'elle a un câlin il est sérieux
série allez allez voilà la vraie
conseiller oui on peut y aller ou pas
oui on voit marais déchiré là vous
n'avez plus qu'à de suivre j'ai tout
choix dans la tête d'accor